[Music]
can you believe it's been 11 years since
we first met the Gosselin's sextuplets
it's true and now they are celebrating
becoming g8 teenagers the year I've been
dreading um well since they were all
born just like every other fairy does
Kate marked the sextuplets milestone
birthday on Wednesday with this week
Instagram post saying I love you guys I
got six times what I planned on but I'd
never ever go back she spent the day
with the kids and shared a pick up some
homemade birthday treats we here for the
kids Hannah Leah Joel and Aaden
celebrated with John the night before
with the family barbeque and Kate in the
backyard since their divorce Jon usually
only gets to have a few of the kids at a
time during his visits I don't know who
I'm gonna get I know I know my heart
I'll get the four that I mentioned
Hannah Leah Joel and Aaden but I really
don't know in any given time I'm gonna
get so what is Jon's relationship with
the kids these days hope I can talk to
them and develop a relationship in the
future but I there's a lot of stuff that
has to go on before that happens the now
teenagers have been on TV since they
were infant
today the sextuplets are still living in
Pennsylvania I've robbed the looks of it
they really love their dogs Nana and
Mack
you
you